coming as absolutely no surprise to anybody.
Donald Trump is issuing a directive that his
lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, not be paid for his work
on election fraud, so-called election fraud for
Donald Trump. And this is not surprising
to anybody. There are still questions as
to whether Trump was completely serious or
only partially serious when he said this.
But it's it's sort of ironic in a sense, because
at the very beginning of all of this, we heard,
oh, Rudy Giuliani is building 20 grand a week
to fight this completely fruitless, pointless,
bogus fight over so-called voter fraud for Donald
Trump. But just because he wants 20 grand a day,
just because he submits a bill for 20 grand a
day to Donald Trump doesn't mean that he's going
to get necessarily paid. And we suspected that
because Donald Trump has a very, very long history
of not paying his vendors. And we've heard
before from would be or former Trump lawyers
that they want clients who pay their legal bills.
And so now, once again, apparently irritated with
being impeached a second time, which happened
two days ago and we discussed it yesterday.
Donald Trump has told people stop
paying Rudy Giuliani's legal fees.
Trump I actually don't really even know
what the connection is that Trump believes
exists between him impeached a second time and
Rudy Giuliani. Rudy Giuliani was fighting the
bogus fight that Trump hired him to fight.
And Rudy Giuliani did speak and talk about
trial by combat at that completely misguided
rally on Wednesday morning on January 6th.
But it was really Trump who said, let's go to
the capital and incited that riot. So I don't
even know I don't even understand the connection
between Trump being irritated with Rudy over the
second impeachment. But as we know, Donald Trump
is unable to take any responsibility for himself
and blames people around him. And the reports are
that he's blaming a lot of people in his inner
circle, including Rudy Giuliani and others,
for the predicament he finds himself in.
And at a certain point, it may be a simple with
Trump, as I blame them, because they didn't
prevent me from doing the things I did and saying,
even though I did them, it's really someone else's
fault because someone else I hired other people to
prevent me from getting into this kind of trouble.
I don't know. Trump campaign senior adviser
Jason Miller sort of said Trump is not soured
on Giuliani, but when he was more directly asked,
is Trump directing Giuliani not to be paid?
Jason Miller did not deny that. He said, I
just spoke with President Trump and he told
me Rudy Giuliani is a great guy and a patriot who
devoted his service to the country. We all love
America's mayor, but no denial whatsoever of the
allegation that Donald Trump is saying do not pay
Rudy Giuliani. One other aspect of this. John
Eastman is this conservative attorney. You
might remember his name. We talked about him.
I believe it's only once before on the show,
John Eastman falsely told Trump, Mike, Mike,
President, Vice Pence, Vice President Mike Pence
could block the certification of Joe Biden's win.
That was not true. And we are now hearing rumors
that John Eastman might join Donald Trump's
legal team. What the point of a legal team is
in the last five days of the presidency, I don't
know. But these are just preliminary discussions.
What would be the plan there? And this, again,
would go towards this idea that Trump, if you can
tell Trump what he wants to hear, you get yourself
into his inner circle. And this is arguably why
Trump's press secretary, Kayleigh McEnany, has
has lasted as long as she has lasted because she
has shown an unfettered, unmitigated, unmitigated
willingness to repeat any lie for Donald Trump and
to defend any action by Donald Trump, never ceding
an inch, never conceding anything. And that's what
Trump wants. And so now, reportedly, John Eastman
has some ideas of things. Trump could do what they
are, I don't know. And there are rumors that with
just five days left in Donald Trump's presidency,
he may be joining he may be joining Donald
Trump's team for what some are calling a
a challenging chapter. Yes, that is certainly an
understatement. And Trump increasingly isolated
and desperate to find anybody that will indulge
his wackiest and wildest notions, were down to
just a few days, my friends, just a few days to
go. And then he will be gone, at least officially.
But we will see to what degree Donald
Trump remains in the public eye.
We have a great show for you today. Make sure
you're following me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We will take a break and have a
fantastic program for you coming up.